[Music]
these are sea turtle eggs and there are
two ways this situation can play out
there's either or there's so how can we
make sure this doesn't end up like this
well take a look again these aren't your
ordinary sea turtle eggs these eggs
could one day take down an entire
poaching network the story of these eggs
starts in Ann Arbor Michigan hi i'm kim
williams qian and i am a conservation
ecologist kim does research on a wide
variety of animals but we're here to
talk about endangered and threatened sea
turtles with sea turtles in central
america there's an issue of poaching of
the nests for consumption of the eggs
and so her team has developed a unique
solution to gather more information
about the poaching trade fake eggs with
GPS trackers we can hide these fake
turtle eggs in sea turtle nests our hope
is that these eggs will get poached
along with the others and transmit
information on their locations where is
it that they go after they're taken from
the beach but for this to work the fake
eggs have to be convincing they have to
have the right feel because sea turtle
eggs are kind of a little soft and
squishy they're not like chicken eggs
we've been using a 3d printer and a kind
of flexible plastic but they still don't
look quite right and this is when our
story moves to Los Angeles hello I'm
Lauren and Lauren works in Hollywood my
day to day job as they work on set as a
makeup artist which could be beauty
makeup prosthetics creature design wigs
blood so it made sense for Lauren to
help Kim make fake eggs we needed these
eggs to look realistic feel realistic
and so that's kind of where I've come in
it was like the best way that I could
use my skills making prosthetics but to
actually like help a whole species of
turtles this is like it's a dream job
after months of revisions it's time to
put these eggs to the test in Costa Rica
heigen you remember Kim she's here to
deploy the eggs herself on a protected
conservation area this is a place that's
very special because it's a very
important nesting site tonight a sea
turtle will come and I can test out
putting the false sea turtle eggs in the
nest not only will this project provide
Kim's team with valuable information on
poaching she and Lauren hope it will
inspire others as well
wildlife poaching can be abstract or too
depressing to even think about something
about this project kind of captures
people's attention here's this very
simple unique solution that I think then
serves as a jumping off point for
people's imaginations to learn more
about this trade all of us working on
this project are just doing it in our
our weird little nooks and wherever we
can and it just goes to show there's so
many little ways that everyone can help
you don't have to be making fake turtle
eggs to make a difference you can make a
difference in your own way
you